después de una jornada de relativa calma
ríos de lava vuelven a fluir con fuerza
del volcán cumbre vieja en la isla
española de la palma estos barones y
regresos a la actividad son habituales
en este tipo de erupciones pero es un
volcán
fisural que responde a un caracter
fisural y estromboliano y bueno pues se
sigue manifestando
como tal yo lo que quiero resaltar es
que es algo normal en este tipo de
erupciones
no nos debe preocupar
estoy hablando nuevamente de seguridad
las nuevas erupciones se producen ocho
días después de que el magma comenzará a
fluir desde la cordillera de la isla
desde entonces el volcán ha expulsado
más de 46 millones de metros cúbicos de
material magmático el pasado domingo la
colada avanzó con rapidez y se encuentra
menos de 1000 metros en línea recta del
mar en ratos del crecimiento y ratos de
decaimiento y en particular las coladas
pues pasa algo similar entonces no
podemos decirles igual llegan o no
llegaron al menos cuatro localidades
están confinadas puesto que si la lava
acaba cayendo al mar podría producir la
expulsión de gases tóxicos por su
interacción con el agua marina es sigue
habiendo dos coladas la del sur esta
tiene unas velocidades muy bajas y la
del norte se ha dividido en el entorno
de todo que de la montaña de todo que en
dos dedos el que va por el norte se
encuentra una pendiente
importante y se ha ralentizado y
probablemente voltee la montaña de todo
que volviéndose a unir con el dedo que
va por el sur que ese sí que avanza a
una velocidad mayor miles de personas se
han visto afectadas por la colada de
lava que ha destruido más de 500 casas
unas 237 hectáreas y el 15 por ciento de
la cosecha semanal de banano de la isla
uno de los principales sustentos de los
locales está en riesgo